men as we launch the counter-attack
against the Union Army must remember
that even though we may die a glorious
death on the battlefield we do so to
preserve a way of life the southern way
of life a way of life so pure and
beautiful that no man no government can
take this away from us
the right
the right to preserve our own son
[Music]
we look fellas we're trying to have a
nice little Civil War Reenactment here
we don't want any trouble
so we sir we will we try to have a real
nice reenactment we certainly don't want
to cause any trouble either do we say
you always taught us trouble only comes
to those who gone down you can sow so
don't stop your speech as Jefferson
Davis okay I know what you're doing how
many times do I have to tell people just
because we're dressed like Confederate
soldiers doesn't mean we're pro-slavery
we're just here to preserve the pure and
beautiful slice of southern history yeah
pure and beautiful slice okay nobody's
gonna whip anybody to just stop it yeah
just stop it all right fellas just just
ignore him all right now we're here to
preserve our way of life the South has a
right to own the south as a way of life
you need to not stop us the Union Yankee
bastards cannot stop us from BART stop
stop it that's enough you want to be
part of this reenactment fine
you're part of it go go go fetch us some
munitions and everything else don't just
Taylor like a bunch of lazy that good
enough for you bad is all I needed to
hear gentlemen give us your cash and
anything that is an actual collector's
item you racist mother okay don't have
all day man okay thank you thank you all
it's wallets wallets wallets it's a very
nice piece
[Music]